é eu sei que já não posso dizer há muito
tempo não janeiro foi um mês
o lado pessoal que quero falar lances
muito menos a europeu estragos aqui para
voltar bem ao canal 1 como a testar um
amigo treinar mas não letal um toque
retal ficando logo estava molhado
pessoal próprio e não conectar um
jogador logo é preciso cumprir primeiro
começa a chegar logo ao instagram me
peçam que joga logo que provar que não
conseguiu evitar por favor pedro stédile
passámos aqui observa que só anunciar
uma coisa eu lancei o meu nome
vamos fria desloca-se enfatizar um
espaço é outra eleição e outra
acontecimento que não pode ser só vocês
já sabem país para 45 em cinemas chega
ninguém vai embora e vá eu já fui ver
toy story 4 lá bem antes tremeu incrível
no filme eu até conseguir conseguir
acesso àquela velha que parece um filme
toy story 4 miguel vítor é só cego não
só que nem sempre dispensado para lá
pessoal afirma estar muito com ela vamos
lá ver o que tem aqui dentro da caravana
isto tá aqui dentro vocês vão poder ver
um filme e ir para lá porque tem aqui
dentro eu gosto de entrar assim eu acho
que a imagem é isso mesmo
eu estava um pouco em campo
[Música]
o gol não tardou muito igual ao filme um
phishing uma cobra das notas é estranho
eu acho que os meus deus
mesmo com o filme não bastaria vencer
junto com maestria 27/8 uso do mesmo
eu agora porque província da huíla é
escolher quem acha sempre fantástico não
eu quero vencer e não mais conseguir o
seu palácio maléfico não vai conseguir
nada é bicho foi assim eu vou chamar o
meu pai
o paa a ver aqueles no filho davi foi
olhada no meu jogo da capcom na roda e
que precisa do laudo e sem precedentes
a resposta não é tão pessoal como testar
um amigo 3 para lá o pessoal escolha vai
ser difícil mas eu acho que o vídeo de
hoje eu vou usar esta máscara de momo
que eu recebi há pouco tempo não é muito
assustadora vamos tentar ajustar o que
com esta marca mas eu tenho mas vou
mostrar que está mais querido até cantar
e tanto em pista mais cruel do 11 9 em
celular a máscara do unicórnio é fofa
portanto não vou usar aqui apenas um
bebê que eu acho que já usei a temos
nenhum e nem sair pink um cavalo eo eo
ponteiro já agora deixem muito mais que
nesse grupo só nós que indicar pelo
menos 25 mil likes e fácil de achar
muito rápido a versão 4 caiu prometeu
faz isso logo já já
a desculpa desculpa eu pensava não temos
aqui um amigo chuva de um bio posso
fazer uma pergunta
eles não dizem que as duas coisas não
tão carregada de pico de 58 e 60 a nossa
chegada
[Música]
lá
[Aplausos]
não não estou falando em nova iguaçu rj
o op
an a casa junto a nós e espero que você
vai pagar para ouvir o relatório deste
ano e segundo o jornal ela foi fazer
coisas bem notório que
[Música]
i am ba os papagaios espanhol
ele também ganhou o campeonato
[Música]
[Aplausos]
uai